there Resident Evil Revelations is meant
to hearken back to the Golden Era of the
series when haunting atmospheres and an
emphasis on puzzle solving took
precedence over rampant action sequences
and massive firefights fans of the
original Revelations can look forward to
the next game coming in early 2015 which
stars CLA Redfield from Resident Evil 2
and her new partner Moira daughter of
Barry Burton from the original Resident
Evil the pair have been abducted under
mysterious circumstances and whisked
Away to an island that's infested with
raging hulks known as The Afflicted the
two have to work together using their
specialized skill sets to make it out
alive and while this has the potential
to form an interesting Dynamic after
playing the first 30 minutes of the game
I walked away feeling like it might also
be a source of frustration as the
adventure goes on the game begins as CLA
wakes up in a dank prison cell without
warning the door unlocks CLA wanders out
and quickly discovers Moira further down
the cell block both of them are sporting
a mysterious bracelet that changes color
based on their level of fear and while
we were told that this would play an
important role throughout the game we
still don't know exactly how as you look
for an escape swapping between Moira and
CLA you quickly get your first taste of
the game's enemies who for some reason
are tirelessly infuriated but they seem
to be infected with something they're
apparently insane rather than sick
they'll attack and bite but they don't
carry a virus crazyer no The Afflicted
are smart and will follow you upstairs
and ladders making it difficult to flee
and avoid conflict while you can hack
away at incoming Afflicted with your
knife you have to turn your hand hand
gun or shotgun to clear a path when the
going gets tough for some unspoken
reason Moira refuses to use a gun which
is probably the most idiotic trait for a
character caught in a life or death
scenario to have it's hard to believe
that Moira would choose not to bear arms
given their predicament this has an
impact on the partner system during
gameplay while CLA is capable of
Defending herself Moira is almost
useless on her own forcing you to
babysit her if you spy an exit as CLA
and try to make a run for it often you
need to go back and save Moira you can
always swap to Moira and blind your
attackers in an attempt to freeze
yourself but if Claire's overwhelmed by
Afflicted and dies it's game over
unfortunately Moira introduces even more
issues in an effort to make her sound
like an AC teenager capcom's written her
character as Brash and outspoken but her
dialogue lacks any degree of subtlety
there's one line in particular that
stands out when Moira exclaims what in
the [__] did I just see what in the [__]
did I just see and to make matters worse
Capcom went out of its way to emphasize
that one word in particular capitalizing
every letter to make sure you don't
interpret Moira as anything but immature
and abrasive no doubt Capcom has its
work cut out for it with that character
but having only played a small portion
of the game it's too early to write her
off completely Revelations 2 could be a
promising addition to the Resident Evil
series but that will only be true if the
partner system works as intended it's a
major component and if Capcom wants to
maintain their commitment to providing
an old school Resident Evil experience
it needs to find a way to make the
player feel like a leader rather than a
[Music]
babysitter